schauen wir uns aber erst zugeschaltet
aus kiew guten morgen paul also beim
g7-gipfel auf schloss elmau ende des
monats ist bundeskanzler scholz dann
gastgeber dann auch für wolodimir
selensky noch in dieser woche soll es ja
aber das treffen mit vertauschten rollen
geben es war in der ukraine
ja der ukrainische präsident wurde mir
selensky erwartet emanuel makro oder
scholz und mario draghi in kiel in der
hauptstadt um auch gemeinsam dann ein
zeichen zu setzen richtung wladimir
putin richtung russland die immer weiter
vorrücken im osten es sind dramatische
tage für die ukrainische armee jeden tag
fast 100 der soldaten die dort sterben
an der front und auch viele zivilisten
die immer wieder um kommen in diesem
krieg
die vorgeschichte dieses besuchs von
olaf scholz war ja nun wirklich ein
diplomatisches desaster muss man dazu
sagen über mehrere wochen steinmeier
wollte dann sollte er aber nicht und so
weiter da gab es ja nur dann wirklich
viele diskussionen so und dann wurde
dieser das blut noch am telefon
ausgetragen jetzt hat scholz dann doch
zugesagt aber er möchte diese reise
nicht machen nur für ein foto was soll
denn dann jetzt tatsächlich kommen was
wird er im gepäck
es gibt ganz sicher zwei themen das eine
sind die waffen die fehlenden worten
lotte ukraine im osten da erwartet man
hier ein zeichen insbesondere von
frankreich in deutschland eben große
waffenproduzenten sind dass sich daran
etwas ändert da gibt es zumindest ein
signal von der nato auf der anderen
seite muss man sagen die usa gehen da
sehr viel bestimmter fortschreiten hat
gestern noch einmal angekündigt dass
noch ein weiteres paket von einer
milliarde euro also im wert von einer
milliarde euro waffenhilfe kommen soll
so weit wird olaf scholz sicherlich
nicht gehen und die frage ist auch wie
öffentlich er dann darüber spricht denn
er hat ja bislang gesagt er macht
angeblich mehr als er sagen kann er will
so seine argumentation das wird man aus
dem kanzleramt eben nicht alles
öffentlich erklären das zweite thema
genauso wichtig fasst ist der mögliche
eu beitritt der ukraine da geht es in
dieser woche um die eröffnung eines
beitritts verfahrens das klingt so sehr
bürokratisch das ist es auch also wenn
da die staaten ja sagen dann bedeutet
das das ganze wird noch dauern also es
ist sozusagen eine perspektive zum
vergleich ein land wie nord mazedonien
wartet bereits seit 16 jahren in diesem
verfahren also das bedeutet erstmal noch
nichts aber es wäre natürlich ein symbol
für die ukraine auch in diesen schweren
tagen ein symbol der hoffnung und das
ist das was die ukraine hoffen paul
thema könnte natürlich auch
kriegsverbrechen seien die fiesen
kriegsverbrechen von wladimir putin du
warst gestern in europa tatsächlich
einem der vororte von kiew die jetzt zum
symbol für putins kriegsverbrechen
geworden sind wir wollen uns mal
gemeinsam anschauen was du da erlebt
ein ort des todes hunderte kreuze auf
frischen gräbern in alpinweiß hier fast
nur männer sind hier begraben sie
starben als die russischen soldaten in
ihren orten fielen viele waren
zivilisten jeden tag sterben über 100
ukraine über 100 schicksale und
gesichter hier auf dem friedhof werden
sie sichtbar wie der 64 jährige victor
seine ehefrau katja und seine tochter
marina stehen vor dem kreuz beinen um
ihren liebsten
als die russen einfielen sind wir nach
deutschland geflüchtet nach hannover
aber mein mann wollte bleiben er wollte
unser haus nicht aufgeben
mein vater kochte gerade es schlug eine
granate in unserem haus ein und schon in
diesem moment flogen später durch das
fenster in seinen kopf zehn tage lang
lager dort auf dem boden der könnte der
dann kam soldaten und fallen der
leichnam wurde in die leichenhalle
gebracht wo er zwei monate lang war und
jetzt kommen wir aus deutschland um ihn
zu beerdigen
sie sind nur bis freitag in der ukraine
dann geht es zurück nach hannover vom
besuch des deutschen bundeskanzlers
erhoffen sie sich unterstützung um die
ukraine zu verteidigen
ich möchte dass der deutsche kanzler
unserem land in dem er mehr waffen als
unsere soldaten liefert bitte helft
unseren soldaten diesen furchtbaren
krieg zu gewinnen
tatjana ist glücklich darüber wie sie in
deutschland empfangen und wie sehr ihr
arbeitgeber sie in der schlimmsten zeit
ihres lebens unterstützt hat und
selbst am grab ihres mannes findet sie
dankende worte
zuallererst möchte ich mich für die
unterstützung unserer flüchtlinge und
für ihre hilfe für die ukraine gedanken
meine tiefe verbeugung vor ihnen allen
an alle die uns helfen und unterstützen
[Musik]
paul ich denke viele ukrainer wünschen
sich dass olaf scholz wenn er kommt dann
eben auch diese orte besucht orte wie
butscher orte wie im team glaubst du
dass er das tun wird
ja ich gehe davon fest aus dass olaf
scholz zusammen mit makro und draghi
einen dieser orte am ende auch besuchen
wird das haben alle staatschefs gemacht
denn das muss man so klar sagen wenn man
hier nur im zentrum von tier unterwegs
ist in anführungszeichen dann sieht man
nicht so viel vom krieg dann spürt man
nicht so viel von krieg wann muss
dorthin und mit diesen menschen sprechen
oder zumindest die zerstörung sehen denn
rund um den präsidentenpalast sieht es
aus wie vor dem krieg natürlich sind
auch in kiew selbst raketen
eingeschlagen aber nicht in der
intensität wie in den vororten butscher
und ihn deswegen gehe ich ganz fest
davon aus dass scholz auch deutschland
heißen wird paul du sagst es gerade ist
fühlt sich in kiew nicht so wirklich
nach krieg an momentan wie ist denn die
stimmung was sagen die menschen wie
blicken sie momentan auf diesen krieg
vor allem auch auf die geschehnisse im
osten
es kommen immer mehr menschen zurück
nach kiew da erlebt man emotionale
momente in polen wenn man sich auf den
weg macht wieder die ukraine wir vor
einer woche hunderte tausende vor allem
frauen die in deutschland waren in polen
waren die zurückkommen dh die stadt mit
koller es gibt wieder staus noch nicht
so sehr wie vor dem 24 februar also
folgen großen angriff aber man merkt die
stadt kommt hier zum leben zurück auf
der anderen seite schauen die menschen
natürlich mit sorge mit angst dorthin wo
die kämpfe sind da sind viele
ukrainische soldaten natürlich auch aus
der hauptstadt immer wieder gibt es
nachrichten über gefallene kirwa
gefallene soldaten zuletzt ein junger
aktivist der nur 24 jahre alt geworden
ist wo man das schon mal 17 jähriger
hier meide anstand und dann im osten das
land verteidigt hier familie her
freundeskreis kennt mittlerweile
jemanden der dort im osten um gekommen
oder verletzt worden ist der krieg der
ist hier durch die ganze ja durch die
ganze
nation sei dank ist es sind halt diesem
moment leider mein ohr
nicht mehr zu hören
wir haben sich gut verstanden paul
dankeschön nach ihr